when you were at Woodstock did you
recognize what a big deal that was or
was to you it's just another gig and
then later on everybody started carrying
on would you did you feel anything
special about that thing well it kind of
there was a buildup
as you know people couldn't get in and
arraign and all that was a big story
right nationwide in in the states and we
were expecting to get flown in by a
helicopter right I ended up going in the
mother-in-law's Volkswagen is that true
why didn't they write but they weren't
able to lay in the hell it was all you
know the typical press you know there's
blown out of all proportion yeah I think
to us it was just it was just another
shot isn't it funny that you even agreed
to do that show when you think about it
because it was all like like like ego
wise who the hell wants to be on the
bill with a whole bunch of other bands
like we used to be on the bill with
those bands all the time that right that
was what was why we wanted to do it
right there you are at Woodstock right
here and that movie I mean that probably
you're what you're cringing you don't
like the sound of that well there was no
monitors we were doing this
always sounds a bit out of choosing me
yet you don't like this vocal
performance I like I like that I like
the energy in it but writing I'm singing
a bit
[Music]
no isn't you it's a true strange echo
it's not the world's best recording they
did not record life here's a goat
singing with not annoyed Susie those
guys and by the way in those days you
probably had no creative control when
they release this movie and the record
and everything else did that piss you
guys off financially like like wow
they're making a fortune off this thing
welcome to all a lie do you not think
about those things but you do now right
you would never sign away the right
Mormon truth over but it shows you how
sad that is in a way because look how to
put everybody on the map well yeah you
know it that's your loyalty of the rock
business get out now who these managers
end up with 10 times more money than any
of the bands
yeah I'm sure when you got when you go
to your managers house and you see them
living in a better house you start the
question would we got lucky